like all right [ __ ] i i i'll probably
wear like a snoop dogg redid the chronic
cat i'll wear that we got to do a
ranking of like the worst
hip hop clothing lines of all time
that's funny that'll be shady ltd
snoop dogg clothing
yums
oh yum's is bad like oh my god that is
horrible dude that and truck fit i just
hate the designs i thought truck fit was
cringy bad yeah like yeah like they paid
me money are we recording recording
okay well listen we have watomi quan in
the building what's happening with
standing we're going to start the show
off ranking the worst hip hop closing
lines of all time
right let's go let's go the candidates
last kings
truck fit
yums
shady ltd
snoop dogg clothing
okay outcast clothing
oh
damn um i think those are probably
are we forgetting any any candidates
i think we're forgetting babe
ice cream bbc no babe babes those i mean
people still wear that that's that's
that's good stuff because cause you said
it great to work i didn't know i mean
the worst oh the world oh we're talking
about shitty shitty ones oh [ __ ] um
i think soulja boy [ __ ] was the worst
yums yeah so we're gonna go yum's is
number one yeah truck fit truck fit
number two number two well truck fit i
was a truck fit dj
and so they would pay me like 500 a
month
to like
they'd send me a box of clothes yeah
and i would always take a picture
holding the shirt up
and post it
i'm saying check out my boys
never wearing it yeah we're just holding
that one and then all my homies were
just wearing truck fit because they
didn't give a [ __ ] but i'm like yo he's
on record talking about sucking dick for
truck fish like don't question how i got
my truck fit so
yeah i'm good on this like wayne kind of
shot himself in the foot yeah um and it
just was uh hideous yeah it it it was so
truck fit snoop dogg clothing and i love
snoop yeah
doggy style is my second favorite album
of all time the album that changed my
life yeah but snoop dogg clothing mm-hmm
was it bad to you
it was really bad well what about the
[ __ ] in the 90s i like the sum of the
jerseys because my my pops he had a few
hockey jerseys
no limit clothing oh [ __ ]
no limit uh
master p loki you know if you had the
master p kicks yeah or you had the
camouflage jersey you was one of them
you was one of them yeah
yeah you was that guy so it's like it
was good bad it was a good bad it was
good
i think snoop dogg clothing i always
thought was like
man a 50 year old [ __ ] would love this
[ __ ]
video
me being like a 17 year old white kid
i'm like i don't know where i'm supposed
to where they should like i don't know
what i'm supposed to do with this yeah
yeah i don't got no enemies i don't got
nobody to bang on so i'm not gonna wear
this i'm gonna say the number three
worst clothing line was eminem's
clothesline though shady ltd yeah yeah
um i will wear some g units and like
that's it
had some [ __ ] yeah i would have noticed
unique clothing was away because it was
like an extension of echo yeah and then
okay remember game had um
game had some [ __ ] too didn't he
yeah yeah shoes some shoes
oh it ain't closed hurricanes yeah the
hurricanes yeah that's the name of them
[ __ ] hurricanes but
uh you said fat form and what else no i
never was a fat farmer oh platform oh
wave yeah okay fat forward no i think
eminem [ __ ] was like yeah if you were
wearing that like
you probably drank mountain dew and like
[Laughter]
your uncle
who who wears a wife feeder and smokes
he lives at home in a trailer he may or
may not have molested you as a child oh
yeah so you're like you know i'm gonna
go to macy's and buy some [ __ ] shady
ltd
i'm not even gonna buy it i'm gonna
steal it because i can't afford it
because i want to dress like eminem
okay who the [ __ ] wakes up and says let
me dress like eminem um suburban baggy
sweatsuits
shady ltd do rag that was white like yo
like yeah remember when eminem was
wearing durags yeah
bad bad
very bad i bet you eminem looks back on
his fashion choices and he's like dude
what the [ __ ] what are you doing man
fight drugs those pills [ __ ] up my
judgment
sorry em i love you and then are we
gonna do last kings is the fifth worst
oh yeah last kings was bad
you know last kings i i just never could
come to the
like as a grown-up in the world
like i'm gonna wear tiger's clothes yeah
but there was people wearing it yeah
yeah it was people wearing that [ __ ]
like it means [ __ ] had side effects
they could just wear their clothes and
be talking
like yeah bro i like going to the mall
like this
just saying tiger [ __ ] when you wear the
clothes that's why i wasn't wearing it
so the top five worst are we we're gonna
go yums
we're gonna go
truck fit truck fit eminem mm-hmm
snoop dogg clothing
oh gee snoop dogg
oh yeah yeah the the other stuff that
you go to burlington and it'd be there
for like 11 years like like the [ __ ]
suits i like the jerseys though
um and then
and then last kings yeah last kings yeah
because at least like last kings i think
some people wore last kings yeah some
people did
my [ __ ] trail king trail he used to
wear that [ __ ] for a couple minutes but
i wasn't wearing it didn't he own it
yeah
[Music]
oh so you had to okay so nevermind you
had to okay yeah he owned the clothing
line
i hope he [ __ ] wore it
jesus christ they had that story on
fairfax that nobody would you oh oh my
god
i'm damn i would drive by that [ __ ] i'm
like yo that's
tiger would have to just pull up though
you know what i mean people would come
yeah [ __ ] gonna slide shout out to
tiger man